[Musique]
l'or n'a pas tardé il ya quelques mois
je me verrais bien à temps déterminé je
vais te dire j'aime bien le jour de l'an
à cause de ça parce que il ya c'est un
alibi pour embrasser des gens là je peux
pas n'importe quel jour en 27 mars soit
1 18 novembre
tombé dans les bras de raymond et
l'embrassé ça ferait le jeu jusqu'à
paris voilà
réglé nous raconter ou vous êtes
rencontrés parce que je suis sous depuis
9 heures asseyez vous vous êtes
rencontrés quelques années comment non
je dis et si c'est pas la bonne oreille
car ils sont les deux qui sont mauvaises
écoutez moi entre les deux oreilles
bon bah on s'assied à côté moi comment
s'appelait ce cabaret vous êtes
rencontrés tous les contenus lui traduit
voilà à 9h à nos fringues gemena of days
and co jean poiret dit qu'ils se sont
rencontrés après la guerre à moscou
il comprend toutes les lans tout non il
fait déjà à l'époque il songe à écrire
la cage ou non on va tout va tout vous
dire on va tout vous dire à 2 nous nous
sommes rencontrés simplement simplement
et il est vraiment nous n'avons rien
fait pour chercher à nous plaire nous
avions nous avions les mêmes effets vas
y on ne sait pas plus ou pire on ne sait
pas plus il a fallu qu'on se connaisse
après des années d année je ne sais pas
si tu te souviens d'un tableau qui
s'appelait la veillée des chocolats là
je sais pas trop si en plantes à cette
heure-ci de la nuit en fête est un
tableau innommable je sais que jean
carmet ray par exemple un un pantalon
trop étroit pour lui attache avec une
grosse épingles de nourrice et il
chantait j'ai du gros bonbon des tables
et quand ils ces tables prof
il perdait son pantalon c'était d'un
goût exquis et ça dure est étaient des
minutes et des mines 8 et celle un wiki
la crégîm boy pour le première fois il
raconté cette histoire de paysans qui
disait on entendait qu'une france était
derrière la firme a buté et tour eux
c'étaient des gros boulot alors
s'adonner aux voix il y encore i télé
duriez derrière la ferme a buté en tout
cas l'option la butée à butée et on
n'entendait que sa bure et des milieux
mais oui et alors ce sont des gens comme
ça qu'il faut pour faire des émissions
de deux réveillons comme ça sur l'état
parce qu'on vous dit subitement vous
avez trois heures et par l'ape l'écart
mais il vous fait ça
[Musique]